que ce soit pour bêcher ce champ en
moldavie que ce soit pour ramasser ces
roches dans une carrière indienne ou
pour cueillir les gousses de cacao au
cameroun le travail des enfants avaient
reculé ces dernières années et dans une
proportion très encourageante en était
très heureux en 2017
la dernière fois qu'on a sorti une
estimation de dire regardez en 20 ans à
peu près 20 ans il ya en a réussi à
diminuer le travail des enfants de près
de 100 millions ses paris à 100 millions
d enfants entre 5 et 17 ans il en reste
aujourd'hui environ 150 millions qui
sont forcés de travailler et à cause du
virus
des millions d'autres risquent de
s'ajouter selon l'onu dans les
conditions de survie quand y'a plus rien
et bien c'est tout le monde qui se met
au travail pour produire la nourriture y
compris dans des formes dangereuses fade
avec des enfants ou bien envoyer
l'enfant pour qu'il ramène de l'argent
pour fêter un à survivre plus de
pauvreté égale plus de risques que les
enfants deviennent une main d'oeuvre
supplémentaire
parmi les secteurs qui emploient le plus
d'enfants il y à l'agriculture les mines
mais aussi ce qu'on appelle l'industrie
artisanale at the comments mais besson
femmes et les haines qu'elle a effectuée
par exemple des familles avec leurs
enfants vont fabriquer chez eux des
pièces de vêtements qui seront assemblés
ensuite dans une usine et les pays où la
protection sociale est trop faible sont
les plus touchés les nations unies garde
pour objectif d'éradiquer le travail des
enfants d'ici 2025
malgré les répercussions de la copie si
mathieu prost radio canada montréal